[Musik]
das podcast ist brought you the munich
soll seine theorie der menschlichen
person vortragen das war der titel den
ich vorgeschlagen aber das ist
eigentlich so eine aufstrebende ausdruck
theorie der menschlichen person ist mir
eigentlich fremd aber die organisatoren
waren sofort begeistert davon
eigentlich habe ich keine nicht so hoch
streben dass ihre theorie der
menschlichen person
ich habe keine besonders oder theorie
darüber was eine person erst im
gegensatz zu anderen nicht person
ich habe auch nichts dazu zu sagen was
etwas mensch zu einem menschen wird am
ort statt zu einem nicht menschen
darüber müssen wir die biologen fragen
was ich dazu was sie zu sagen habe das
betrifft uns und wir sind auf jeden fall
menschliche personen
ich habe eine theorie über uns das
trinkt immer noch ziemlich hoch streben
eigentlich will ich nur etwas zu unserer
natur sorgen
ich habe keine vollständige arterie über
unsere natur ich will nur eins sagen
über unsere 100 natur und das haben sie
ja schon gehört wir sind tiere das heißt
biologische organismen die these ist
nicht das unserer körper tiere sind das
ist ja ziemlich unabgestimmten a
das kann ja fast jeder sorgen sogar kart
hat das behauptet mein körper ist eine
ist ein tier
ich sage ich bin ein tier wir sind alle
tiere
ich will nicht sagen dass alle personen
die es entweder gibt es einen gott
vielleicht gibt es immer wieder gibt es
menschen die nicht tiere sind wer weiß
vielleicht sind sie pflanzen auf den
affen morgens darüber habe ich nichts zu
sagen ich sage nichts über gott
okay lass das motto man braucht nicht zu
beengt und so weiter nur über uns ich
sage auch nicht dass alle tiere personen
sind vermutlich sind schnecken keine
personen nur dass manche tiere personen
sind in der regel sind das die ersten
personen interviews und das menschliche
menschlichkeit menschliche personen
zumindest im normalfall wir sind alle
personen und wir sind alle tiere okay
nun das klingt vielleicht nicht
besonders aufregend
das müssten sich schon das petit oder
sind sie sehen sich im schauen sich im
spiegel an
da steht ein tier das man sieht sich
selber das ist hier also sind die tiere
aber wenn man die geschichte der
philosophie anschaut und wenn man frägt
was die großen figuren der ndr info so
viel geschichte dazu gesagt haben haben
sehr viele gesagt dass wir nicht tiere
sind zum beispiel platon augustinus anna
dekan und so weiter die großen figuren
haben fast alle gesagt dass wir nicht
jedes den sodann etwas anderes das lässt
uns seine nachfolger sind eine wichtige
ausnahme von dieser regel nun warum
sollte jemand abstreiten dass
die tiere sind wie kommt man zu der
überhaupt zu der absicht dass er etwas
anderes sind tiere in die geschichte hat
es meistens zwei gründe
insofern haben das vorhaben das für
unmöglich gehalten dass ein tier oder
überhaupt ein material der gegenstand so
denken kann wie wir denken können
aber wir können nicht tiere seien weil
wir denken und und an sonstigen
psychische eigenschaften haben diese
eigenschaften sind unverträglich mit der
materie nur nur materiellen dingen kann
er keinen denken wir können denken dass
es ja und zwar aus so sind für
immaterielle dinge und nicht die anderen
großen figuren der philosophiegeschichte
haben gesagt es gibt sowieso gar keine
tiere es gibt eine materielle
gegenstände sind gar nur erscheinungen
nicht gehören nicht zur wirklichkeit
also können wir nicht hier sein
heutzutage ist dieser sogenannte
animismus immer noch recht recht
umstritten es war mal eine eine umfrage
vor ein paar jahren trafen david und
charles
eine dieser fragen die sie haben mehrere
tausend fans offen ganz so rund um die
welt gefragt was so aus als ob etwa 30
philosophische fragen gestellt um
herauszufinden wo sie zu wie sie zu wie
sie zu bestimmten großen rhetorischen
fragen stehen von dieser fragen ist es
darum gegangen ob er tiere sind oder
nicht ich weiß nicht genau was sich
gehört waren ungefähr 1 führte und dafür
dass offen haben gesagt wir sind tiere
und haben gesagt nein wir sind nicht
oder zumindest etwas ein antwort gegeben
die impliziert dass wir nicht tiere sind
warum ist es so wie es ist kann man auch
so in diese materie besten zeiten er ist
immer noch abgestritten von den meisten
der soffin sei gerade das wie tiere sind
der hauptgrund hat mit der sogenannten
personale identität zu tun
personaler entität ist ein sehr
schwieriges wort das kann sehr vieles
bedeuten aber wieder verschiedene sachen
das worum es jetzt geht ist unsers uns
unser weiter bestehen
über die zeit hinweg ok stellen sie sich
vor ich werde einige gedankenexperimente
ihnen vorstellen
das ist jetzt das erste nicht so
aufregen stellen sie sich vor sie hätten
ein ein klassenfoto ok mit ganz vielen
kleinen kindergesichter ok und sie
sorgen der da das bin ich okay das ist
das gedankenexperiment könnte man fragen
ja warum ist sind sie dieses kehrten
nicht dieses oder dieses oder dieses
oder gar kein essen was macht es
überhaupt also dass sie damals existiert
haben warum sind sie nicht erst heute
vormittag in die welt gekommen war
welche beziehung zwischen ihnen diese
jetzt sind und dem kind vor 1000 jahren
war welche beziehung ist es was ist also
macht dass sie dass sie und dieses kind
identisch sind die gleiche person
warum bin ich dieses kind doch nicht ein
anderes ok und die als etwas seit 300
jahren lag
ist die beliebteste antwort auf diese
frage dass die dass es mit der
psychologischen kontinuität zu tun hat
ich bin deswegen dieses kinderlied ein
anderes weil es bestimmte psychologische
beziehungen zwischen mehr wie ich jetzt
bin und diese kenntnis damals war zb
kann ich mich erinnern wie dieses foto
gemacht wurde oder wenn nicht das dann
kann ich mich zumindest ein anderer
sache nennen die in der zeit passiert
sind wurde
ich kann mich an sachen erinnern an die
ich mich damals an die sich dieses kind
erinnern konnte meine mein jetziger
psychische zustand meine jetzige
personaletat und und und und und so was
habe ich von diesem kind geehrt
natürlich ist vieles geändert hat sich
vieles geändert seit seit damals aber es
gibt eine eine kette von psychologischen
verbindungen zwischen mir so wie ich
jetzt bin und diesem kind ließ dann muss
man das machen
das ist der grund warum ich dieses kind
bildstock stadt statt drei anderen okay
das ist die das ist der renner
das ist die beliebteste theorie über die
personalie identität seit 30 jahren und
diese diese diese die diese
psychologische kontinuitäten theorie ist
mit dem ein mann ist muss und
verträglich ok sie können das tor durch
sehen wenn sie sich bloß an ihrer schule
biologie
sie wissen doch dass menschliche tier
als winzige embryonen anfangen
aha dieses tier war einmal ein winziges
embryo aber das winzige embryo hat ja
keine überhaupt keine
psychologische eigenschaften damals es
gibt also überhaupt keine psychologische
kontinuität zwischen mir und diesem
winzigen embryo das tier hat mehrere
monate überlebt ohne jegliche
psychologische kontinuität
wenn ich auch so ein tier bin dann hast
du mir das damals möglich dass ich ohne
psychologische kontinuität weiter
existieren kann wahrscheinlich heute ist
heute auch möglich ich könnte einen
schweren unfall haben nochmal
gedankenexperiment okay einen schweren
unfall haben dass meine psychologie
zerstört völlig zerstört und nichts
bleibt übrig ich bin völlig bewusstlos
aber das hier und es so sehr beschädigt
das bewusstsein und und denken und so
weit denn nicht mehr möglich ist okay
aber manchmal kommt es vor dass das tier
immer noch lebt in einem vegetativen
zustand in dem fall kann das team auch
ohne jegliche psychische psychologische
kontinuität weiter existieren und diese
tatsache kann man zum zu einem vorwurf
machen gegen den terrorismus
jetzt brauche ich einen habe ich jetzt
etwas zu verwischen
und das hätte ich denken so
das wird ja hast du zu erkennen
noch besser das bist du und das ok jetzt
wird dein gehirn in meinen kopf
transportiert
okay mein hier ankommt bringen die in
die maschen tonne dein hirn kommt in
meinem kopf okay ja und was bleibt übrig
da bleibt ein tier übrig mit einem
leeren kopf ok ich glaube dieses
gedankenexperiment normalerweise
beschrieben wird gibt es psychologische
kontinuität zwischen dir und diesen
typen hier unten
ich verrate noch nicht wer das ist
aber dieses
dieser mann wird vermutlich denken dass
er ist ok er wird erinnerungen haben an
seine erziehung und erwirbt glauben ja
und in seiner wohnung und das mit ihrer
frau oder mit ihrem mann verheiratet und
so weiter und so fort
er wird nicht alles gleich sein wird
wahrscheinlich irgendwelche
psychologische änderungen seien die
herren und selbst in der ihren gedanken
experiment das nicht völlig reibungslos
das gibt es immer komplikationen sind
aber nicht so wichtig auf der anderen
seite wird dieser mann keine entweder
man von meinem reden und radiert meine
meine vorlieben meine meine lebenspläne
usw
nicht nur haben diesen aber weg ok meine
psychologie ist zu ende gekommen
deine psychologie ist zumindest im
großen teil diese menschen zu finden
jetzt okay wenn lok und die psycho oder
psychologische kontinuität freunde wenn
sie recht haben dann bist du diese
person
okay was passiert aus den tieren
wir hatten doch zwei tiere am anfang von
diesem experiment ist dieses tier jetzt
dorthin gekommen haben wir das tier von
seinem eigenen kopf herausgeschnitten
viel viel kleiner geworden
in einen anderen raum getragen und dann
haben wir diesem tier dann wieder neuen
teil neue teile gegeben um die
irgendwann um die zu ersetzen die
die ihm vor am anfang oder geschnitten
wurden das scheint nicht der fall zu
sein scheint dass dieses tier hier ist
das tier lebt sogar noch weiter wenn die
operation
wenn ich hier drücken sehr sorgfältig
das gehirn rausnehmen und vielleicht
noch in ordnung und uns vielleicht noch
einige künstliche hilfsmittel einsetzen
die sonst bei schweren unfällen sind
okay und was wird und dieses tier wir
unten dieses tier war nicht viel
dies ist hier war niemals so klein war
niemals ein prozessieren dieses tier war
für mich oder zumindest mein körper oder
irgend sowas
es scheint so als hätte die operation
ein organ von einem thema zum anderen
übertragen
okay ein teil von dir ist jetzt teil von
diesem tier ist jetzt so ein teil von
diesem anderen tier geworden genauso wie
bei einer nierentransplantation okay
wenn wir tiere sind dann bin ich das mit
deinem kehren und mit einer völlig neuen
psychologie und falsche erinnerungen
falsche überzeugungen
ich würde natürlich denken dass ich ein
anderer mensch an eine andere person bin
aber da werde ich unrecht haben okay und
du
naja sieht schlecht aus aber so ist das
es ist ja nur ein gedankenexperiment
auch jetzt keine angst haben dieses
resultat kommt stellten viele
philosophen akzeptabel zumindest
zumindest unattraktiv ok und wenn man
nur über dieses gedankenexperiment
denken kann und andere ähnliche
gedankenexperimente denkt kommt auf die
idee dass das falsch ist und dass die
personen doch mit dem transplantierten
nieren gehen würde
ok und das würde bedeuten aber dass wir
nicht tiere sind
mit ihr ist dann war meine beschreibung
richte
und wenn diese wichtig dann sind dann
sind wir nicht okay das ist die die
hatten
der hauptvorwurf gegen den organismus
jetzt ist ja okay ich gebe jetzt zu dass
dass dieser vorwurf etwas gewicht hat
das ist vielleicht doch wenn man an
nichts anderes denken ist das vielleicht
doch ist dieser gedanke doch attraktiv
dass man dass man mit dem gehirn gehen
wir der stadt mit der mitte werden
häuser so zu sorgen
ok nun es gibt noch ein
gedankenexperiment ein ähnliches
eigentlich das wenig nur weil es sein
lieblingsauto entfernen denn nur der
bäcker erste frau in diesem raum heuer
gesprochen hat sich der sich vor sie
könnten ja völlig
organisch werden wenn ihre teile ihrer
organischen teile eins nach dem anderen
durch künstliche künstliche prothesen
ersetzt werden
aus der pfanne mit dem tier an und wir
ersetzen erstmal den den rechten arm mit
einem mit irgendeiner prothese aus
edelstahl oder kunststoff oder oder
kohle versagen oder regens ist okay dann
machen wir das gleiche mit dem anderen
an
und das gleiche mit den bäumen und
anderen grund und wird selbst meine
pumpe ein fürs herz und so weiter und so
fort irgendwann wird auch das hirn
vielleicht stück für stück mit
irgendwelchen tricks siliziumchips dann
ersetzt es wird vorausgesetzt bei diesem
gedanken experiment das dass die
psychologische kontinuität hier
irgendwie auch gewährleistet wird also
dass es möglich ist dass ein computer
oder irgend sowas nicht richtig denken
kann und und unbewusst sein haben kann
und psychologisch genau so sein wie ein
mensch okay das wird vorausgesetzt dass
ich jetzt nicht abstreiten obwohl das
sehr
absteiger ist okay am ende von diesem
vorgang
es gibt es
ein völlig anorganisches wesen aus
edelstahl kupfer und so weiter
das genauso denkt wie der mensch am
anfang und auch psychologische
kontinuität
damit dieses ding auch glaubt dass es
von dort aufgewachsen wo diese person
ist um so weiter und so fort
ok und sie meint dass sie das überleben
könnte okay man könnte auf diese weise
also sein es ist seine seine organischen
teil der völlig fertig schulklassen und
frakturen sterbik werden weil der
roboter wird ja dieses ding das ist auch
mit dem warum das weiß ich nicht so
genau das der grund ist ein streik bei
diesem da da gibt es ja psychologische
kontinuität also ziemlich also wenn sie
90 mit dem transportierten gehirn da
werden sie wahrscheinlich auch zumindest
sie werden es zumindest attraktiv finden
den gedanken dass sie dieses diesen
vorgang auch noch überleben könnten
das ist aber auch mit der therese
unverzüglich das fed ihr das sind was
passiert aus dem tier
der rechte arm gestellt wird das tier
wird kleiner und kriegt aber ein
einziges werkzeug stadt sind okay aber
das werkzeug gehört eigentlich zur
umwelt von dem tier das wird ja nicht
nicht in organischer stoffwechsel
begriffen und so weiter ok und wenn das
recht abermals jetzt wird dann wird es
hier noch kleine uns und um uns so geht
das bis vor dem ziel überhaupt nichts
mehr da ist
ok dann spätestens da existieren mehr
existiert das tier nicht mehr
ok man kann ja nicht sagen und dieses
diese roboter hat aus winzigen sample
angefangen
ok nun wurden glaube ich dass wir tiere
sind jetzt gibt es keine genauen
experimente mehr das richtige bett lag
aber
der grund das wort ich glaube deswegen
dass wir sind weil ich es für möglich
halte dass tiere denken können
organismen keine psychologische
eigenschaften haben das ist nicht völlig
unmöglich
ok hunde zum beispiel können schmerzen
für ok schnecken vielleicht sogar auch
tiere können können denken und kann ein
bewusstsein und aber unser weiteren wenn
das so ist wenn überhaupt organismen
psychologische eigenschaften haben dann
können menschliche tiere psychologische
eigenschaften haben dieses tier kann
bewusstseinszustände haben es kann
denken und so weiter aus das ist meine
erste käse das ist jetzt merkt absolut
recht gerechter umstritten was ich jetzt
sage okay a
dieses tier denkt okay
und wenn dies ist hier denkt dann denkt
dass vermutlich genauso wie ich denke es
wäre ziemlich merkwürdig wenn dieses
thema so ein bisschen denken könnt aber
nicht
nicht so wie ich wenn das tier ein
bisschen schlage aber nicht so schlafe
ich das ist übrigens allerdings die die
neuen von der bäcker sieht glaubt zwar
schauen das menschliche tiere denken
können aber sie hält es für männer
physisch unmöglich dass irgendwelche
tiere sogar menschliche tiere mitten im
leben unmöglich dass sie so denken
können wie ich wie wir sie können nicht
heißt das also was ich haben kein
selbstbewusstsein sie haben keine sie
können nicht in der ersten person denken
warum das so ist hat sie nie erklärt
soviel ich weiß dass es mir ein rätsel
okay das lege ich die ist ihr denkt und
es denkt nicht nicht nur das sondern es
denkt okay das ist jetzt vielleicht
umstritten aber das ist zumindest nicht
eine verrückte idee das ist dass das so
ist
ich glaube auch dass ich denke dass es
nicht so umstritten
was würde
was wäre wenn ich denn dieses tier so
denken würde ich aber wenn ich kein tier
schon etwas anderes
dann gäbe es das denken die tiere und
das geben die denken der personen das
wären es war ja dagegen stellte das team
und die person die beide beide denken
bei decken die gleichen gedanken dann
wählen beide dinge die person und das
tier und das nicht viel
sie werden beide personen zumindest mit
einer person einfach etwas ist was die
die intelligenz und die psychischen
eigenschaften von uns okay es gibt also
zwei personen hier
es gebe zwei sorten von personen es gebe
vier personen und nicht die personen und
von für jeden menschen gebe es zwei von
diesen personen eine bis jeweils 15
eine person in einer nicht der person
okay das ist ja dass ich würde das gern
einmal zeigten wie das ist mit dem mit
mit der tiere personen der nicht hier
personen aber das fällt mir schwer
am besten wird das geht mit zwei
verschiedenen formen aber das habe ich
nicht da die trotzdem das ist das tier
person die der person
ok und irgendwie ist hier auch eine das
ist das tier und das ist die person
ok und beide sind wie soll man sagen es
ist schwer das ist das tier und das ist
ich solle mir so okay ich bin eine
person ich denke das tier ist auch eine
person in das denkt genauso das ist für
viele personen und da müsste ich mir
wirklich überlegen welche person bewusst
wenn ich das tier oder wenn ich das
nicht tue und was wird aus mir werden
wenn mein er transportiert werden würde
wäre ich mit dem hirn mitgehen oder mit
wer dich wirklich zurückbleiben aus wäre
gut das ist vielleicht keine so wichtige
frage denn das wird nicht passieren
okay aber ich würde vielleicht ja auch
gerne dessen ob ich jemals ein kleines
embryo war oder nicht
ich würde vielleicht gerne wissen was
aus mir werden würde wenn ich in einen
relativen zustand versenken würde das
unfreiwillig das tier oder würde ich
weiterleben aus in einem unbewussten
zustand
ok und diese fragen wären unnötig zu
beantworten ich könnte niemals wissen
so wie es aussieht welche natürliche
person ich bin cara dass die tiere
besser oder die nicht die person das ist
ja ja das ist das ist nicht so schön
diese diese dieser diese these also
werde ich sehr gerne behaupten
es gibt nicht zwei personen oder 2 gegen
städte die so wie ich denke hier das
tier und etwas anderes ok und aus diesen
drei prämissen wird es dass ich ein tier
bin okay und das ist der grund warum ich
glaube dass ich hier bin und die die die
tiere gegen ja sozusagen die die diana
das muss geld nötig wieder so find ich
glaube dass wir nicht tiere sind müssen
eine von diesen thesen vereine und
wahrscheinlich wird es diese sein sie
werden abstreiten dass dieses teams und
denkt ich es irgendwie obwohl dieses
tier ein völlig gesundes und erwachsenen
hat obwohl ihm gar nichts fehlt
irgendwie aus irgendeinem grund ist es
möglich groß war dass ein tier ist ist
es nötig dass das tier so denkt okay und
wenn das wirklich so ist dann ist es
wahrscheinlich unnötig das überhaupt
jedes update tirol irgendein
biologischen organismus soll denken kann
wie ich und wahrscheinlich ist es auch
unmöglich dass irgendein lebewesen
irgendeiner psychologische
eigenschaft haben könnte das ist einfach
mit der physischen möglich das leben und
die psychologie sind unvereinbar und
verträglich es kann sein denken und
bewusstsein aber nichts kann beides sein
das ist die objektive zum kommunismus
entweder sie besorgen
das ziel denken können dass psychologie
und biologie doch verträglich sind
wenn das der fall ist dann kann dieses
tier denken und in dem fall bin ich
dieses tier dann habe ich die probleme
nicht
wie viel zeit habe ich noch genug
okay das ist dieses argument das recht
das ist vielleicht darum gestritten
jetzt habe ich etwas über die attraktiv
was ist was sind die alternativen denn
nicht tiere sind was da was ist die
alternative
ungefähr vier alternativen gibt es jetzt
wichtig dass wieder weg wenn wir nicht
hier sind was dann ist kann sein dass
wir etwas initiiert das sind okay wir
sind überhaupt keine materiellen
gegenstände müssen etwas immaterielles
wir könnten vielleicht in materieller
substanzen seien die platten unter
karten seid nett gemeint haben park und
viele andere
wir können vielleicht einfach eine
sammlung von gedanken seine sammlung von
von von von von geistes zustände auch
wirklich entweder so oft dass gedanken
gedacht hat ist unklar
vielleicht ist er nicht oder vielleicht
irgendein kann tisches ding an sich was
weder räumlich noch zwei kontertore kein
tier sei wegen etwas völlig unbekanntes
aber nicht meint er
das ist eine möglichkeit ok ich hätte
sehr gerne ein argument dass diese
möglichkeit völlig verrückte sprengen
würde aber das habe ich nicht
ich sage jetzt nichts mehr über diese
diese diese these und wieder möglichkeit
ist könnte jetzt könnte es sein dass ich
hier bin
also ich bin kein tier sondern ein teil
von einem tier welches teil von dem tier
war vermutlich dass hier und es gibt
wirklich will das duo für 90 tage die
das land der importe zum beispiel
mannschaft mit neuem haben ans gehirn
also nach ihrer ansicht bin ich
eigentlich viel keine aussicht das
scheine ich bin völlig in meinem kopf
versiegelt kein mensch hat mich jemals
gesehen oder irgendein teil von mir
gesehen sogar ich selber nicht
wahrscheinlich würde wenige leute würden
mich sehen wollen so diese philosophen
müssen dann sorgen warum ich kann hier
nur ein hier den warum sind meine
grenzen überhaupt von meinem von meinem
schädel und nicht weiter warum sind
meine hände meine füße nicht teile von
und meiner meinung nach haben sie keine
gute antwort auf diese frage aber das
ist ein anderes thema und haben richtig
aber nicht zeit das zu erklären
dritte möglichkeit ist kann sein
vielleicht sind wir gar nicht existieren
wir überhaupt nicht vielleicht gibt es
gedanken aber keine denker okay das ist
ich sage zwar ich denke ich esse ich
schlafe und so weiter aber das ist nur
dass unsere grammatik zwingt uns zu
dieser redewendung aber eigentlich hat
das wort ich unternahm hat es keine
referenz des ssk es gibt überhaupt keine
denke sondern nur gedanken
[Musik]
es gibt auch eine trägt auch nichts
darüber sorgen heute okay das würde
vermutlich auch heißen dass es keine
zelte gibt
aber wenn es tiere menschen tiere gibt
dann würde man erwarten dass die tiere
das dass manche von diesen tieren
personeller dass sie denken können uns
und so weiter vermutlich gibt es
überhaupt keine normalen gegenstände
wenn wir es wenn sogar die nicht
existierenden gibt es vermutlich auch
keine tische und keine gebäude und
keiner keine planeten und heute
vielleicht gibt es nur atome oder irgend
sowas
ok dann gibt es diese die theorie die
der beko zum beispiel
sie sorgt wir sind nicht ihre wir sind
von tieren konstituiert wir sind nicht
hier aber wir sind von tieren
konstituiert okay was bedeutet dass wir
sind von tieren konstruiert das hört
sich gut an aber was hat das eigentlich
zu bedeuten
das bedeutet ungefähr so viel ich
verstehe dass wir ziemlich genauso sind
wie tiere aber doch irgendwie anders
okay wir haben andere modelle
eigenschaften
manche sachen sind für uns möglich die
verkehre unmöglich sind und auch
umgekehrt
man kann auch diese diese ansicht mit
mitteln ordnet mit einem anderen
gedanken experiment ja ich habe
versprochen dass das keine aber das ist
wirklich das letzte gedankenexperiment
also wir fangen mit einem klumpen
trockenmasse trauen einfach wir machen
diesen gruppen erstmal kugelförmig und
dann fällt uns irgendwie an war
demotivierend diesen kunden aber in die
form von sonja kohn ist natürlich von
angela merkel und dann am nächsten tag
werden wir vielleicht unzufrieden damit
den bestand und den ton wieder ein
es ist man denkt vielleicht es gibt hier
einen klumpen ton der erstmal kugelfänge
gestern daran merkel dann wieder da und
fragt einfach einfach so wie ein klumpen
okay aber es scheint vielleicht auch
dass wir nicht nur diesen krumpen
verändert haben wir haben auch etwas
geschaffen eine statue ein kunstwerk und
dieses kunstwerk dieser stadt war
niemals gruppe für mich okay und sie
wird am nächsten tag aus wir den die
station stand wenn sie wieder zerstört
und nicht bloß nicht reguliert so nicht
wirklich zerstört ok und das wäre selbst
wenn das nicht so wir selbst wenn der
gott der fans oft einfach diese stadt
diese statue aus toren von angela merkel
einfach so aus dem nichts erschaffen
würde wäre es immer noch möglich dass
der klumpen ton das einstampfen
überleben können
werden wir das anstellen würden würden
wir nicht machen was ich manchmal was
ich da tue so schön ist aber wenn wir
das machen würden wäre die stadt wird
zerstört
sie wird jetzt zu ende kommen okay aber
der klumpen ton wird überleben
er würde immer noch existieren okay nun
der kunden ton und die statue haben wenn
das wenn das alles stimmt haben
unverträgliche eigenschaften sie sind
zwar physisch identisch die sind aus dem
gleichen atom gemacht kein physische
unterschied aber sie haben andere
moderne eigenschaften das was sie
überleben können ist anders diddy diddy
und klumpen krank sachen überleben was
die statue nicht überleben kann zwar
vielleicht auch wieder umgekehrt
vielleicht kann die stadt ursachen
überleben was die der kunde nicht
überlegen kann vielleicht wenn wir ein
teil einordnung vielleicht einen neuen
ersetzt und aus anderen ton und wird
vielleicht und und wir schmeißen den
diesen irgendwie ein sehr reiches vorher
vielleicht das ist völlig verbrannt wird
okay da hört der trunk auf zu existieren
das ist dann weckt das wird zerstört
aber dich darüber gibt es immer noch nur
aus teilweise anderen tun
ok nun wenn das alles stimmt das dass
diese konstanz konstitution theorie ok
dann wenn das stimmt dann gibt es
vielleicht gegenstände die männlichen
tieren stehen etwa so wie die statue zu
den ton kunden steht also für sich
identisch aber mit anderen modellen
eigenschaften zwei verschiedene
gegenstände die verschiedenen vorgängen
überleben können sie können außerdem
bekommen genauso wie der kunden und die
stadt führen
ok und auch die geschichte mit der hirn
transplantation das habe ich jetzt nicht
mehr aber sie irren sich doch noch dran
wenn das wenn das hirn transportiert
wird dann geht die person mit dem hier
aber die das tier bleibt so wie ist das
möglich
das 240 identische sachen verschiedene
wege gehen können wo das ihnen das
gleiche passiert wird das gleiche
passiert naja das ist nicht anders aus
in diesem fall
wir machen das gleiche der stamm von des
1 das gleiche passiert beiden gegen
stellungen 1 überlebt und 1 nicht
genauso wenn ich denn diese diese
schreckliche unfall passieren wird und
ich würde meine psychologie studiert
wiederum das tier wird das überleben
aber die person nicht die personen
weiter für uns existieren obwohl sie
physisch identisch sind
okay das ist die so genannte
konstitution theorie
also jetzt sage ich ein paar sätze zu
konzentrations serien dann höre ich auf
okay nun die konstitution freunde müssen
zwei fragen beantworten mindestens war
aber zumindest doch erstens müssen sie
erklären wie es möglich ist dass die
zwei sachen die für sich identisch sind
doch in anderer hinsicht so verschieden
sind was hat die der klumpen das es
möglich macht dass dazu dass das
einstellung von über- leben kam und
warum kann die starts über die das
verstanden nicht überleben das ist die
frage ist nicht ist nicht leicht es ist
sss es genügt nicht für sorgen dass das
was nach dem einstand von übrig bleibt
keine steuern mehr ist es wird nicht
daraus dass die statue nicht mehr
existiert nur dass sie keine stadt mehr
sind ich könnte auf den philosophen zu
sein könnte in ruhestand gehen und
irgendwas anderes machen
das wird aber kein wieder aufhören zu
existieren der philosoph heute gebe es
immer noch das ja er kann für das hoffen
auf möglichst dass die stadt zwar immer
noch existiert aber doch keine starts
mehr ist also wie warum können
physisch identische gegenstände so
verschiedene identitäts bedingungen
okay das ist die erste frage aber nicht
nur das sie müssen auch aber etwas
anders erklären nämlich warum keine
tiere nicht denken okay aber wir haben
ok das ist wirklich anders
transportation geschichte
diese zwei dinge obwohl sie sollte zwar
das sind zwei dinge erste gleichen
material
da das tier und die person das tier
konzentriert die die person aber wenn
das gehirn rausgenommen wird kommt das
tier dorthin und die person kommt
dorthin so das ist das ist das ist eine
gute frage warum zerstört das
einstampfen dich dafür aber nicht der
kunden
ok selbst wenn wir die frage der brief
frage beantwortet haben haben wir immer
noch die frage warum kann dieses tier
nicht denken
und wenn es denken kann jetzt aber doch
nicht ich dann gibt es wieder zwei
personen 1 die tiere person und nicht
die personen die nicht die person dann
könnten wir nicht wissen welche personen
wir sind rock tierversuche nicht die
personen sind
das wollten wir vermeiden also müssen
sie auch noch erklären warum tiere nicht
denken können
das ist schwer die fragen zu beantworten
die frage muss aber eine antwort haben
die konstituierung theorie richtig
noch ein letztes wort wenn sie sich in
der literatur zu wir soviel des geistes
herum wesen kommen sie vielleicht auch
dem begriff von zombies das hat nicht
die zombies wie den wie in den autos
testen sondern wie zombies die die sich
di di di di di di di bewusstsein
schwärmer als sich ausgedacht haben es
gibt leute die die das bewusstsein für
irgendwas ganz besonderes halten und ok
als sie glauben dass die qualitative der
qualitative charakter von bewusstsein
irgendwie nicht für sich geschrieben
dass das nicht physisch bestimmt wer das
das dass das bewusstsein eine nicht
physische eigenschaft ist okay warum
glauben sie dass ein grund ist folgendes
ich glaube dass es möglich ist
sie glauben dass das bewusstsein von den
physischen tatsachen den eigenschaften
nicht bestimmt wird also es könnte etwas
geben was für sich genauso erst an die
ich zum beispiel aber doch kein
bewusstsein hat es wäre dann ein
sogenannter zombie okay für mich genauso
wie ich aber ohne bewusstsein sie
erwarten das ist möglich oder wenn ich
musik tanz zumindest vorstellbar okay da
wird schauen was wir zum beispiel gerne
argumentiert
so und wenn das so ist dann sagen die
diese katastrophe
es wird daraus das bewusstsein keine
physische eigenschaft ist das ist das
ist auch so ein tolles musste der
eigenschaften zu diesem argument gar
nichts sagen
aber jetzt wenn man das mit mit dieser
aussicht kombiniert dann kommt es dabei
etwas interessantes heraus es kommt
heraus dass zombies nicht nur möglich
sind sondern dass es sie wirklich gibt
die die zombie freunde die eigentlich
sorgen dass zombies zwar mutig sind aber
wahrscheinlich nur dann wenn die
naturgesetze
ganz anders dann könnte es sie geben
aber es gibt sich wirklich nicht so wenn
diese ansicht stimmt dann gibt es sogar
schon zum bis dieses tier ist und zombie
denn dieses tier ist identisch mit mir
identisch ich bin bewusst ich habe
dieses qualitative bewusstsein was zu
besonders ist das tier hat es nicht okay
wenn das tier das hätte dann wird das so
denke ich und dann gebe es zu viele
es gibt wahrscheinlich noch andere
zombies also jedes mäßige teams und
zombie wahrscheinlich gibt es auch was
anderes wenn es nicht nur staub zu holen
aus ton gips sondern auch klumpen
tonklumpen gibt dann gibt es vermutlich
auch vielleicht klappen
es gibt ein zwei stunden her dass zu mir
steht sowie die der toten zu dieser
stadt immer von angela merkel stellt und
diese fleischwunden wer dann auch mit
mir physisch identisch aus dem gleichen
stoff gemacht die die gleichen
physischen eigenschaft
wie ich aber die darum ein bewusstsein
das wäre dann ein zweiter zombie und
vielleicht gibt es noch mehr
also gibt es in diesem raum sogar mehr
zombies aus personen
das wäre jedenfalls eine sehr
interessante gut da höre ich auf